all right guys
bang bang jeff is back for round two uh
this time we don't get to do it in
person
uh thanks so much for doing this man my
pleasure good to be back
absolutely for those that didn't watch
the uh the first time you were on maybe
give us a quick kind of 30 seconds on
your background
uh and then a little bit on bedrock and
kind of what you guys are doing
uh from a venture standpoint sure so uh
founder of founder of bedrock we're a
technology investment firm
that i founded a little a little under
three years ago now
we manage around half a billion dollars
really invest across
all stages all sectors um you know
frankly all sorts of different um asset
classes within
within technology as well some of our
more well-known investments
include uh rippling um rig up
uh the athletic lambda school um
cameo uh and and we're investors in some
crypto stuff as well
uh before starting bedrock i've been a
partner at uh at founders fund for a
number of years where i led
early investments in companies including
lyft wish
uh new bank uh canva um
and and sort of a number of others that
have ended up being really successful so
my passion in life sort of finding these
uh these counter narrative companies
these companies that are somehow
overlooked or underestimated
uh by but by uh by folks that that sort
of uh
determine what the popular narratives
are on and backing those backing those
entrepreneurs and
and that we we've been at it for a while
now and and i love what we do
so when you guys first started bedrock
you wrote this epic letter that
basically was like
here's who we are right and part of the
the messaging that you guys have really
uh kind of championed is this idea of
narrative violations and
uh there's a lot of people who i think
was like oh that's cute marketing uh
what the hell does that mean
but now we live in a world where over
the last six months uh it's become very
obvious
uh some of those near narrative
violations uh and one that you've talked
a lot about recently is this idea that
all tech is good
uh or all tech can uh kind of build a
better world
talk a little bit about why you put that
in the category of kind of being a
narrative violation and
what the implications of that are so i
actually
did not say that all tech is good so
what i what i said is that the popular
narrative
um so so the thing with narrative
violations is uh is they exist on this
time scale and so basically
um you know uh there's a there's a
moment that
these narratives uh can can go from
being very popular to being
uh to being uh to be sort of counter
narrative uh very very
very quickly and so with technology in
particular
uh you had this narrative in the 80s and
the 90s
that technology was building a better
world and that was sort of the
the consensus popular narrative so if
you looked at sort of the media elite
uh the business elite um the the popular
narrative was silicon valley is good you
then had google launch in 2000
with the model don't be evil and then in
the early 2000s
leading up to probably all the way to
that up to sort of
2010 2011 uh google sort of
categorically perceived as the don't be
evil
uh very good company uh you had sort of
the myth of steve jobs
and and so there was this sense in which
silicon valley technology was like
they were the good people in business
that was sort of the good
uh the good-hearted well-meaning saving
the world
way to be in business was to do
something in technology in silicon
valley
and that became the narrative on silicon
valley fast forward to today it's 180
and and the narrative on silicon valley
now today is
uh tax text destroy tech's destroying
the world we have to break up all the
big tech companies
uh they're they're all these they're all
monopolies the tech founders are all
evil
uh and uh and and and uh and they're
taking and they're destroying the world
and
and what we would argue at their we
argued in our letter and what i believe
is that
neither of those extremes is true and
it's it's this company
uh specific company by company type
thing
the problem for silicon valley though is
um
instead of uh sort of all along being
like actually things are more nuanced
like
you know silicon valley is not
definitionally going to save the world
like
could be good or bad just like any other
business um silicon valley writ large
um bought into this yep we are the way
to to make the world a better place
and um and i was complicit with the
narrative gatekeepers on the propagation
of this narrative of
tech is the way to make the world a
better place so the fact that it is
now exposed to not be entirely true and
somewhat more nuanced
is a bit of a problem for silicon valley
to put it put it mildly
yeah and so one of the things that uh
you've kind of laid out very clearly is
uh this idea that you've got to live
outside of these narratives or live
outside of these frameworks because if
you don't then you run the risk of
getting
framed or labeled and kind of put within
the narrative
talk a little bit about like how does
somebody do that in practice
well the easiest way to do it uh is to
is to be what i what i call
what i call digitally disengaged so the
easiest way to do it actually to be
uh just not not engage digitally
obviously
uh the ship uh the ship has sailed for
you uh paul
the ship sailed uh to a much lesser
extent for me
or you're a much bigger digital brand
than i am but certainly the way to
the way to the the the obvious way to do
this is simply not
not do any not have any online profiler
to do it
um via entirely via pseudonym so that
would be sort of the
the easy way to uh to um to
uh to to to avoid getting framed by a
narrative would be to not have a persona
uh that that that that's public and one
of the things that
um that that uh you know unfortunately
i've chosen not to pursue this strategy
it's always difficult to commend a
strategy that one's not pursuing
themselves but
a strategy that works extremely well um
is to
certainly when in a fund manager context
and even in an entrepreneurial clinic
there are a lot of phenomenal
entrepreneurs there are a lot of
extraordinarily
uh successful fund managers that just
don't have a public profile
that just issue all press that don't are
not on twitter and on social media
like you if no one would know who they
are and they do they do phenomenally
well
i think there's a lot to recommend that
uh in a world where these narratives are
are are for forming so quickly
coalescing so fast
and can run over anyone that doesn't
conform with the narrative there's a lot
to recommend
that digital digitally disengaged or uh
or pseudonym driven type type online
online online presence now that said
as we know um there's a lot to be said
for for having a digital uh for being
engaged online i mean it it can bring
it can open up a lot of doors it can
result in a lot of opportunity
certainly it's been very beneficial for
me in terms of finding
entrepreneurs building relationships
getting access to opportunities
probably the same is true for for you
and um and and so there's a lot of
benefits to it
but then there's always this way in
which uh in which uh
you you you're exposed you're exposed to
the mob and all of these in all of these
ways and uh
and and i think that that dynamic just
intensifies more and more going forward
for sure uh and part of this is uh you
said that warren buffett
we have more to learn about the
narrative than uh the investing
from him in some ways uh what do you
mean by that
well um you know i say the um
the investing strategy i'd say could be
summed up as something like too dumb to
fail
um and that's a credit to buffett i
really like two dumb to fail things i
think that's the type of thing that you
want to
be investing but sort of like these sort
of blue
you know blue chip type assets then
smaller
smaller companies which is really strong
fundamentals that'll last for decades
sort of this
to them to fail strategy with enough
capital to go
get get these really meaningful
positions or own these own these
businesses over
over many decades that that to me sort
of a two-dimensional fail strategy so
credit to him for pioneering it
um but then i think more impressive is a
how he populi
popularized and uh and and and became
synonymous with that with that strategy
quite frankly was a pretty obvious
investment strategy that
a lot of folks pursue at at subscale
versus versus berkshire but uh but
certainly became synonymous with that
brand himself around that
and what's narratively brilliant about
it as a as a strategy is it's a strategy
that
um anyone can tap into and execute on a
smaller scale and so it's like a
it's a yeah buffett's doing it but i can
buy these blue chip stocks also
bmi 401 k or something like that so
there's a sense in which it's like uh
um something that's accessible to any
person who's who's sort of you know
middle class or
or or more uh which which has a very
populous type vibe to it
but the more impressive piece to me um
is how he's managed to to brand himself
um as uh as just as an everyday joe who
just wants to give away all his money
and um and and uh and you know
if you google you google jeff bezos
house
you'll see like 50 60 pictures of
various
30 000 square foot plus mansions and
cities around the world
la dc washington uh
seattle um you know various
international destinations here you
google
bill gates which is 100 million dollar
thing in seattle this is these other
properties you google
these uh these other folks they've got
various yachts et cetera you google
warren buffett you see lots of pictures
of his
is admittedly nice but it's a it's like
you know it's it's a pretty standard
suburban house it's not
out of reach for you know if you're like
a lawyer living in suburban
suburban illinois you could you could
sort of afford the house the buffett
uh lives in in omaha and
and there's there's lots of pictures of
that house you know he's it's it's
he always mentions you know he drives
he's he's known for being just very
frugal and living this very modest life
that is a narrative and um the giving
pledge
um which which buffett co-founded with
with bill gates
um again credit credit to them i think
it's great that they're giving away
pledging to give away the vast story of
their net worth during during their
lives and that's a wonderful thing
but that is also a narrative and it was
it was
uh and so i'd say he is the master
amongst ultra
high net worth millionaires and but to
be clear like billionaire
is like very separate from
multi-millionaire and billionaires very
separate from
um from like even like having 100 or 200
million dollars it's like a totally
different category in terms of like the
degrees of freedom that you get when
you're a billionaire
i'm not one to be clear um and and
um but i know a few and um and to be
able to brand yourself as
as sort of not like the other
billionaires
super generous um you know just lives a
really frugal life
you don't really care at all about money
i think that is like true narrative
mastery and then buffett's achieved that
yeah one of the uh institutions in um in
society that is uh very dependent on the
narrative and uh the confidence game is
the federal reserve
uh and kind of this belief in money
belief in their ability to
be able to manipulate interest rates and
and the money supply in order to
keep an economy moving in the direction
that they want uh
obviously they've been making a lot of
decisions and taking action
and a fear from that is inflation
uh what are your thoughts in terms of um
does it happen does it not happen how do
you think through it what's the impact
on
both early stage and late stage
companies just kind of what are your
thoughts on inflation in general
sure um so with the caveat that i'm not
an economist
uh so so i definitely don't view this as
any sort of uh
expert ex not an expert on this stuff
but
i have a few thoughts um one is um
uh um we just had the announcement today
from the chairman of the of the fed
uh jerome powell um that they're now
targeting
um uh they're targeting higher inflation
for the next five years i think than
than have been historical so certainly
the fed now is explicitly
um now just today there's now a major
policy shift
but they're going they're explicitly
announcing uh that they're going to
allow influence
inflation to run um run higher than
normal
um and uh and so the fact that whenever
you have a
sort of announcement um an announcement
saying hey this is like ben
and positioned as this is this really
good thing we're gonna let inflation go
up
it's like really positive it's five year
new
new thing that we're doing it's really
good for everyone to be slightly higher
inflation
you always want to be skeptical in a
questionable way that's
sort of like it's like oh cool like
that's know helping us all out by
increasing inflation certainly would
want to want to be a little bit
skeptical about about that and so
the fact that the fact that they felt
they needed to make an announcement
about it
uh to me means that like uh we are just
it is just going to be this
extraordinary
extraordinarily inflationary environment
because they're really for years to come
because there really is
at this point no other option
um you know the money printing that's
gone on the trillions and trillions and
trillions of stimulus
um there is just no other option than to
then than to pursue a monetary policy of
of inflation and so you know there's
there's there's this question
on um there's this question on whether
that macro dominates micro
um for for asset classes and so when you
talk about
a technology stock specifically and this
is private market companies public
market companies
just talk about technology marks stock
specifically
in theory and and in practice to date in
a
um in in a hyperinflationary environment
where digitization trends are being
accelerated by a global pandemic
um the macro would would point to um you
know you you obviously can't be in cash
in a hyperinflation environment so
you want to be in the in the in the in
the uh
equities that are most linked to sort of
um
the future and and have the sort of the
most expected value
in the in the future and that would be
technology so there's a very strong
macro story for
for technology investing whether you're
at the early stage or even in the public
markets i mean
would have done phenomenally well just
investing in the public markets and in
in technology companies over the last
seven eight months
um and then uh and then you have to
juxtapose that against
um uh against i actually don't think
kobe's impact
has has actually flown through on a
micro level
uh um into the numbers um for a lot of
these
uh highly valued sas companies so
excluding the
excluding the e-commerce stuff i think
the e-commerce stuff
the the uh you know things like zoom is
an exception to this on the south side
social media all of those are are are
probably just phenomenally accelerated
by covid but
on enterprise south specifically i think
the upticks in churn
have really only started to hit these
companies over the past few months and
um and ultimately you're gonna see the
sas uh
people aren't gonna hit their their q4
numbers for a lot of these large
enterprise sas companies and i think the
multiples might get
might get signed accordingly so i'm much
more skeptical of the micro story on
on tech investing i think the macro
hyper inflation
uh you know where how do you get a
return on one's capital in the future
bodes well for well for technology
so you came up with these uh five
predictions uh a couple of months ago
um let's just go right down the list and
uh and kind of check in on
how you think that they're going uh the
first is the death of dr
lee uh as the franz ferdinand moment
uh in society
uh yeah so you know in world war um
you know so there was in a in a in in um
so it's early right where i'm at i can't
it was i think it was world war one yeah
franz ferdinand so
in world war one uh retrospectively the
historians looked at the assassination
of this um
of this uh this austrian austrian duke
franz fernandez game sort of the initial
domino that fell that sparked um
that sparked world war world war one and
um and i would argue that uh i would
argue that um that this death of dr
lee um uh this uh this um
this uh this wuhan doctor used this
wuhan i believe he was
actually uh an ophthalmologist he was an
ophthalmologist in wuhan
um very early on in um in sort of uh
in uh in um in sort of december uh
between christmas and new year's
uh he was he was sending warning
messages he saw he was alarmed by um
by uh by some of the cases that he was
he was seeing even as just an
ophthalmologist
and he was was sending wechat messages
trying to warn people
um of uh of of this as being a very
serious
uh risk of of pandemic and it ultimately
contracted corona
virus while treated treating a patient
as hospital uh and and died
and i believe that that um that death
that death of dr lee
historians a hundred years from now if
if we have historians it's
very unclear we'd have historians
anymore in the future but if we even
have historians
they will look back on the they will
look back on that death of dr lee
um as a friends for ned moment for a new
major
global conflict over that will that will
unfold over the next
number of years and uh and um you know
i'd say maybe the initial domino was
you know his death is emblematic of the
initial domino being
um you know this coveted outbreak not
this covered outfit
being underplayed by the the chinese
communist party
um doc you know dr lee trying to warn
about it dying of the virus he's trying
to warn about the virus then escapes
from wuhan
spreads globally there's questions about
whether the virus was
was actually you know a bat born
coronavirus from a wet market
or it was was there was a there's this
allow was it a lab leak
uh there's all these things that they're
very weird about the origin story on the
virus
and then all of the dominoes that have
fallen since in terms of how
this epidemic is is is is just has
is impacting every facet of geopolitics
and every passive the way we
we live around the world that i believe
will this
will look back on that as as a transfer
and end moment just firmly stand by that
prediction
the resurgence of religiosity
uh or basically the the uh
popularization again
of religion well we're already we're
definitely seeing it there's there's new
religions that have really sprung up
um and uh they're too dangerous to name
so they're not going to
name what that what they are but there
are certainly new new religions that
lots of people are really passionate
about
every night on various city streets and
and um
and and that's fine and if they want to
that's that's totally cool
um you know and uh and so there's new
religious
religions that have sprung up um i think
that people are turning more inward
becoming more
um more sort of spiritually centered
certainly even though a lot of the
churches have been intermittently
closed if you talk to friends of mine
who are christians
they're like uh the the the turnout for
the online services
uh the digital extreme services is like
higher than ever um and i think people
are searching for
for meaning because the basically the
frame that we had
for um sort of a basic stable framework
for like how
a reality uh sort of reality is i think
has been somewhat fractured
um by like the global response to the
virus over the past
um you know seven or eight months so so
yep still stand by that one
uh hyperinflation and uh maybe caveat
this one with uh us or not us
and any sort of idea around timeline
so um so we're already seeing inflation
so that's so we're not at hyperinflation
already seeing inflation
and then you know i always like to be a
little bit hyperbolic with predictions
so it's possible that i was
hyperbolic in predicting hyperinflation
perhaps i should have just predicted
inflation but that would have felt a
little bit too boring
um you know i i i think it'll flow
through over
five years so it sort of began the
prediction was time time time um
you sort of had to have it was time the
times it was a five year time scale
and um in theory it should be worse and
um in theory it should be worse and
um you know there's all these southern
european countries that that
where where it should be a lot worse the
number of these developing countries
would probably be worse in other places
than in the us
uh this one is fascinating to me which
is remote work as a narrative mirage
yeah so um so i don't know like what
it's gonna look like
but i don't think this like working from
home indefinitely
thing um for all white collar jobs um
is is actually like the new is actually
the way it's just gonna be going forward
so
i don't think we're returning to like
suburban office parks
and uh and and certain and certainly so
certainly that's done so i'm i'm very
short so we're in office parks i'm short
i'm short the skyscrapers in midtown
manhattan
i am i i don't think it's going to look
like it looked before
but i do think people want to be um
want to have interactions with people
that they're working with and i actually
think that there's something fundamental
about building a company
where you you kind of have to have some
real
sort of in-person interaction so
i think maybe the one way in which this
prediction could be wrong
is if vr for uh for vr just gets so
so good on a fast timeline that like we
have these immersive virtual offices
that we all just
put on our headset and we're in this
immersive virtual office maybe that's
the way in which the prediction could be
wrong
but if that doesn't happen i predict
there's some sort of new way of
of of working together that's not fully
remote and i think that ends up being
um something that we're not expecting
and so on the extreme end
um on the extreme end of the of the way
in which this prediction would become
true
would be actually if ai automates all
the white collar jobs that are
that we're now doing remotely so that
would sort of be the that and i do think
that's possible on a
five-year time horizon so i think
actually you have a
possibility of ai automating just a lot
of the white-collar zoomer
jobs such that just you know you're
still going to need a plumber
you're still going to need a landscaper
uh but you're you're
not gonna need a you're not gonna need a
um you're not gonna need an
uh an accounting clerk um and and all of
those zoomer white collar jobs are just
are just gonna go away they'll be
automated
that's one way in which this remote work
things in their mirage
two is um i don't believe it's a just
permanent
change so i think once the pandemic is
solved
which again i think is gonna take a lot
longer than most people think it is i
think it's gonna take
many years but i think it's gonna take
less than five years
and once it's solved people are going to
be desperate to
to engage again in person and so i i do
think it is a
over hyped narrative and and uh and uh
uh likely to be a mirage does zoom
count as part of that vr experience
well my thing with zoom is
um i think that zoom is like sort of
yahoo
so i i so so so i i feel i look at
zuma's yahoo so like
you know yahoo was like the breakthrough
sort of web portal and search
engine and then it was disrupted by
google and the main thing with zoom is
it i think it makes
at least i feel like it makes me look
really ugly and so i don't like to do
the zoom things
i think it makes my room the room look
ugly it makes me look ugly
um it's it's not a very good price it's
quite kludgy um
as a that's a word would use the
technology of like it's a it's
it's not a super slick product
experience so i think there's room to
disrupt zoom
maybe though maybe it's the new vr what
do you think
i mean it's possible but uh i i just
think that
um i find it hard to believe that the
first iteration
of the solution for something that was
such a shock
right like everyone just scrambled and
basically said how do we do this
solution one is zoom
uh it wasn't necessarily purpose built
for this um and so
you know you got to believe in kind of
technological progress that there will
be
other iterations that are improvements
off of this now that could be from
zoom or could be from you know other
companies but it just feels like
sitting and staring at each other on
video while we like type on our
computers
probably isn't the solution if remote
work ends up being the
the kind of uh standard right yes i'm
inclined to agree with you on that
all right number five uh serological
test
agreements which sounds like it's out of
a sci-fi movie but
has got to uh probably be uh be somewhat
realistic at this point
uh yeah i think it's pretty i think i
think i think that one was
in the uh generally in the right zone
but i think i got
the specifics a little off so rather
than like an sta and what i mean by sta
is like just as you sign an nda when you
have to walk into an office at a lot of
companies
they have these digital mbas you used to
have to sign back when we walked into
offices
i imagined a future in this five-year
time scale
where you'd have to pledge that you had
antibodies to the coronavirus or
had recently tested negative for the
coronavirus i actually think that
companies not governments are just going
to scale up
uh the rapid testing now that we have
these rapid tests that you get results
in five minutes
i actually just think that like you you
go to go to any workplace you'll have to
get a rapid
you'll have to do a rapid test before
energy like you go to reception you do a
rapid test
you self-administer it maybe maybe you
have to have a medical professional for
the first few years overseeing the
the reception areas of these offices and
workplaces but
i do think certainly for me before i'm
ready to like host a big business event
or like have have all of our our
portfolio companies come together for an
off-site
i'm not doing that until i have rapid
test results on myself and everyone else
like come on
um so so i do think that is going to be
that is going to be the
the future and and and the we're finally
getting the testing
capabilities are starting to come online
to do that and
and then ultimately yeah maybe it does
transition to more of a
a serological task agreement which is
what i predicted
yeah one of the things i keep thinking
through is just if this is persistent
um what are the other changes to society
that happens so if you go back like take
new york real estate for example
uh there was immense capital inflow from
international
investors in like the mid 2010s builders
saw this they all got super excited they
went they started building a bunch of
stuff
by the time they actually got the
buildings built there was more capital
controls in asia
a lot of that kind of capital flow got
shut off and now there's this
overabundance of empty apartments all
throughout new york and it's just
because by the time the demand actually
or also the supply got to the market the
demand had kind of dried up or at least
lessened
and it feels like there's the
possibility to your point
even if this virus stays for another you
know year to 18 months
people are making a lot of changes
whether it's to the way they work to
their locations you know whatever it is
and by the time they actually get a lot
of this implemented we may be on the
tail end of it and therefore
uh it's kind of a lot of uh motion that
ends up not actually leading to progress
because you almost got to revert back to
the world you know pre-coronavirus right
yeah um so your point being
um a lot of these changes um it just
ultimately just reverts back so it's
sort of pointless forward motion is that
sort of the general point
well i think that you're basically
trying to make permanent changes for
what is probably a temporary problem
and so if you if you don't think of it
as a temporary solution you think of it
as a permanent solution
you actually end up doing things that uh
you know hurt you in the long run
because you basically
reacted incorrectly right if it's only a
temporary problem
then you should create a temporary
solution not a permanent type solution
where
you know let's say all of a sudden
skyscrapers in new york started saying
you know what we're actually gonna
uh drastically uh change the way that
the the floors are laid out
and you can only you know now people
have to go in and rent four floors
rather than two
because of the spacing and then in 18
months it goes back
can you actually get back to the norm
kind of as fast as as you made the
change i
just don't know right okay so now i get
what you're saying
so um so here's what i'd say on that so
i think
there's a sense in which that's the
exact right frame and so i think there's
a
there's a sense in which if um
there's a sense in which that's the
right frame um and
and uh because i don't think it changes
things in the way that people think it
will change things and so
um and so it's sort of like um
uh all the obvious things that one
um you know that one would do um
maybe maybe don't make sense so like uh
so sort of like if you were
super long uh midtown manhattan
commercial real estate
i would sort of be an obvious move to
try to liquidate your
midtown manhattan personal real estate
portfolio now but
then in practice there are no buyers for
that portfolio and so it doesn't make
sense to do that
you'd have to sell them for pennies on
the dollar salt for pennies on the
dollar
so the obvious moves just financially
don't don't make don't make sense to
make right now
but then i do think there's a i i
actually i don't agree with you that
it's or i don't agree with the assertion
that it's a temporary
problem because i think that what i
think that plagues if you look
there's sometimes there's certain
moments where we actually have to really
look back
thousands and thousands of years and see
how things have played out in historical
context
and with plagues in particular they
really do
change things uh they change even they
change who we are
uh and they and they and they change our
our nature as a
as a society um and uh if you look back
as far as like the plague of athens
uh which was an epidemic that devastated
um ancient greece in like 430 bc
um and uh and uh it was sort of came at
this
in the midst of this peloponnesian war
um it led to sort of the the fall of
that empire
and um and there's a there are all of
these knock-on effects
and uh second and third and fourth order
of facts
of um of these uh of these plagues
um that um that are only become clear
retrospectively and so i would imagine
that
a hundred years from now again people
will be looking back and like
yeah like sure the chromebooks like
manhattan like yeah people started
working
in midtown again and like that but
there's there are all these other ways
in which
in which um in which it just gets uh
you know things just get really changed
so for example
um you know one one way in which things
get really changed in manhattan
specifically would be
um you know with the tax base flight out
of new york
i don't know how um how they can
how the government's gonna be able to
afford to maintain the
the cities really even at all or and so
you know maybe maybe like yep there's
still lots of
skyscrapers in midtown manhattan but
they're all occupied by
by by government agencies and sort of
albany expands to manhattan
and uh and uh sort of aoc's office is
is is in the penthouse of the vampire
state building or something i don't know
but
i think i think i think things change
just not the way we think they will
that would be epic uh and i don't know
if a good way or not
but uh in terms of uh going back to
technology world
pro startup anti-big tech that is a very
very popular narrative today
i think you've said you can't really
have
that stance like those are
contradictions to each other being pro
startup and anti-tech
or anti-big tech how do you kind of
settle that or balance
that that idea yeah i mean the the whole
idea of like what we do at bedrock what
i do is
we were investing in these super early
companies sometimes it's just
um a few a few ladies in a in an
apartment in brooklyn where they're
where they're quarantined
uh working on coding something to get
coding something up and uh and it's
really just a bet on the people
and uh and and and and the idea and the
market opportunity
and implicit in doing that you have to
believe that it will one day be a big
tech company
and so implicit in doing the early stage
startup investing
uh in order to to have that be a
profitable endeavor
um one has to believe that some of the
companies that you're investing in when
it's just a few
you know uh men ladies um
you know uh um whatever
however anyone should identify you know
their gender you know a few people
working together on something
um uh uh earl when there's really
nothing other than just their vision
them their like raw abilities and a
market opportunity and you're giving
them you're writing them a chat
just based on that you've got to believe
like implicit that
you you hope it one day will be a huge
tech company and so
i find it like this very convenient but
like
completely incoherent position when i
see technology investors
who are just categorically like we have
to break up all the big tech companies
all the big tech companies are evil but
make their livings
by investing in these early stage tech
startups like that to me just seems like
an incoherent position
and there actually are more than a few
again i don't
view myself as a venture capitalist i'm
a i'm an investor
you know some people get to
self-identify as vcs
i just self-identify as an investor um
that's my personal identity and i'm
laying claim to that
but uh but um but certain vcs
certain vcs out there are pretty vocal
about the fact they they think all the
big tech companies are evil and need to
be
government broken up by the government
but are but are making their living off
investing in startups and
and that feels very incoherent now
that's not to say
that some of the big com tech companies
have done bad things and deserve to pay
a price for
for doing those things but i don't think
being categorically anti-big tech is a
coherent
is a coherent position well and it leads
to this
um kind of thing that people forget
which is that
every challenger or disrupter if
successful
becomes the man right so so i think
that's kind of your point here and we're
seeing this play out perfectly with
apple versus uh fortnite and apple is
you know they used to be the the people
in the garage right they were the ones
who were gonna go disrupt the uh the
tech world and kind of
um the the computer science and software
world
now everyone's pointing the finger
saying you're the big bad person who's
you know
preventing me from running my business
the way i want to run my business and so
how do you analyze fortnite versus apple
i know you called uh
fortnite's uh thing the uh the greatest
corporate
uh propaganda ever uh i tend to think
when i saw it but it was
absolutely awesome that the way they
kind of executed this whole thing
but but talk a little bit just about
that that showdown between
you know two really just heavyweights
and um
over the financial relationship that
they have yeah i mean
um it it is uh it's
uh it was a brilliant move by fortnight
you basically have the situation where
you have apple
um you have apple uh has been this just
really important distribution channel um
for
for these for these for these companies
these games these businesses
and um and uh and the reality is that um
the reality is that
uh sorry the reality is that when you
when you're when you're generating the
demand
as fortnight's fortnite's doing um
when you're generating the demand um
uh um you you you you're able to capture
you're able to capture the to capture
more of the value and so
there's this um there's this thirty
percent tax that that that fortnite has
to pay apple
um that epic uh has to pay apple to have
fortnite on the app store
and um and and yet they're able to
generate their demand for fortnite
via all these different paths you know
they've got consoles they've got
other um other other other mobile
devices
um all sorts of ways people can engage
with fortnite they are not
to completely path dependent on ios
um and um and um and so there's a sense
in which you know my partner eric
stromberg has this
my partner at bedrock has this great
website street screenshot essays.com
and he would sort of i think term the
app store
like it's becoming more of a dumb pipe
for media companies like epic
like fortnite um because uh
because um they just have the leverage
to negotiate down the tax
uh they're not fully path dependent on
the app store
and so you know as eric says epic was
the first to make a move here but
they're not gonna be the last
i i i also love the whole um
it was such bait right it basically was
like let's negotiate let's negotiate
let's negotiate okay you're not gonna
cave
they just waited and it's very obvious
they had the lawsuits ready they had the
marketing video ready
like everything was lined up and they
went ahead and they just said we're
gonna do it anyways
and then uh i didn't know this until
recently they actually sent an email to
apple
saying we just did this so they didn't
even wait for apple to go find it like
they basically like
you know said to him you know we're
putting the middle finger up apple took
them off and then that's when they kind
of unleashed everything
uh and look that's like that's something
you would have expected from apple 30
years ago
right like that was a very apple-esque
move not you know but today they're just
the man
yeah um well they're the man they're the
man acting like they're not the man
which is
which is which is the right the right
way to do it in today's world
absolutely uh solopreneur platforms
uh you've got a couple of tweets out
there of uh these things just taking off
right throughout the pandemic
uh kind of up 200 or more many cases uh
we're talking about the shopifys of the
world etc
um kind of how do you view that um is
that something that is
a narrative violation and will kind of
uh come back down to reality or is that
a
change that is likely to stay
um i i think that that is a new reality
so i i think like but whereas before you
would have opened up a
you know you would have opened up a a
coffee shop or
um or some some sort of uh you know a
comedy club or something like that in a
city
um these businesses are just going to be
built online and so the new way to build
a small business
is online but different from you know
the sort of platform dependency
um for these for irl smbs for like real
world small businesses
the platform dependency is basically on
local government so you sort of are
dependent on local government instead of
local government
regulations to operate so that is a
platform dependency
uh to use tech jargon and then you're
dependent on like you need a landlord if
you have a physical space so that's your
platform dependent on some real estate
and energy infrastructure you need sort
of power and electric
and and and and that stuff and now
there's a new set of platform
dependencies if you're
doing a shopify store or if you're doing
a rolling fund or if you're doing any of
these new or podcast business
there's sort of a new set of platform
dependencies that you're that you have
as a solopreneur
whether that's you know shopify plaid
stripe
um distribution for a podcast you know
spotify
app store whatever like whatever your
there's a set of platform dependencies
so
i think the solopreneur thing was always
a trend we just didn't call it solo
being an entrepreneur starting a small
business as an individual or with with a
loved one or with a friend
that's always been a thing it's now just
migrating very quickly
to this this new set of platform
dependencies online
and uh and i think what what you want to
be very careful of is if when you're
going down one of these solopreneur
paths
just be like thoughtful and strategic
about what platform dependencies you
have
and like epic like fortnite i ensure
that you're not overly dependent
on one platform for distribution so like
fortnight was able to stick the middle
finger up at apple with this ad
because they know that they can survive
without the apps or distribution
you never want to make a threat unless
you're actually willing to follow
through on it and so like
they know they can survive without it so
there's a lesson for every solopreneur
from that fortnight
uh for tonight's position where you
never want to be too dependent on one of
these platforms
absolutely and and do you feel like
those platforms
uh they're the ones who kind of build uh
greater and greater product suites if
you kind of look like a square right
they've been able to build a whole suite
of financial services
uh versus uh maybe something like a
robin hood just stay just in brokerage
right that's in the fintech world but
when you move to these
uh platforms around these solopreneurs
will we see that shopify's kind of build
an entire product suite
and kind of go full stack where somebody
can just show up and just use shopify
and build out their entire business
or will we see kind of multi-platform
dependencies so
i need shopify i need stripe i need uh
plaid you know i kind of need all of
these different pieces to build my
uh my platform rather than just i can go
partner with one and just use that one
platform
yeah i mean i'm not sure i
i think the reality is that um
it would be um it would be better for
the well it'll be more
work and annoying for the solopreneurs
to to have these different problems they
have to work with it's actually better
for them because it
you don't have you're not giving any one
platform like shopify too much power
but in practice i think what will happen
is they'll all build out these full
stack suites and so
you will be able to just choose yeah i
want shopify for everything if you're
doing an e-commerce
storefront or like i or or one of the
other options or i want
stripe or paypal or whatever for for all
of my my
payments rails and all that so i do
think they increasingly end up just
becoming directly competitive
as they as they scale over over the next
number of years i mean if you just
think about like banks as an analog like
there are like
lots and lots and lots and lots of banks
in the united states
with total assets uh you know that are
over a billion there's like something
like 40 banks that have over a billion
dollars in
in total assets um in the united states
and sort of
um like you know like lots and lots of
banks with
multi-billion dollar uh market caps and
there should be
lots of these enabling uh and if you're
a small business owner you typically
would only work with one bank
and so similarly i think you would
generally you'll have one of these
platforms that you're more dependent on
got it what areas are you guys looking
at right now in terms of if there's
entrepreneurs building
uh in certain verticals you guys are uh
would love to talk to them or learn more
yeah i mean it's it's it's it's always
uh we're we're much more like
we're much more just opportunistic so we
feel like we're not really very good at
coming up with ideas so we tend to just
be much more opportunistic and
like to just see things in wherever a
few areas where we've been more active
recently
i have been in in the defense sector
i've just given our view that
that global globally things are becoming
more unstable
it feels like there's more room for
innovation in the defense sector
uh and that we we sort of do need new
new technologies there's that's an area
that we've recently
uh become become more active in another
one would be
you know we talked about one of my
predictions resurgence of religiosity so
given i have you know we have a
prediction there people are
more interested in faith and meaning
trying to find it in new places
that's a theme that we're actively that
we're actively pursuing
um and then we do actually think that
these enabling infrastructure companies
you know you have you have shopify that
help um sort of our you know you had
this wave of um
this wave of like uh of um of uh
of um of centralized sort of
things the centralized e-commerce thing
with amazon there's essentially shopify
is the decentralized e-commerce thing
you know the sense in which plaid is
like enables you know
any any app to let you connect your bank
account i think these sort of
core infrastructure type type things
there are more opportunities for that so
we're always interested in these new
new areas that are going to be core
online infrastructure going forward
got it and then in terms of the current
portfolio you have
uh you've got a bunch of businesses that
end up
appearing at least from the outside to
be well positioned for a digital first
world that we've moved to so things like
lambda school and education space or the
athletic
on the content side maybe talk whatever
you can share in terms of like
how the portfolio generally has been
able to uh to benefit from some of this
shift
uh as have many of the technology
companies in the public sector et cetera
yeah i mean um
i i would i would actually sort of argue
that um
that uh that uh the that that some of
the
the bigger positions um were maybe more
exp
more exposed to covet risk than uh than
than i than i would have blogged so just
for example
so for example well let's take the
athletics so you have a shutdown
shutdown in sports so right now we've
got the nba bubble right
it's sort of so it's a sports
description media site
um and then there's there's no sports so
so so there's a sense in which like it
is um
uh there's a sense in which uh that
that's not great for the athletic as a
business when there's no
when there's no sports so now all of
that
said what i've been shocked by is how
resilient
that the companies have been including
the athletics so like you know they've
they've
the chart they're still growing uh you
know now you've got
you've got the end you've got the nba
bubble stuff is is driving more coverage
and and i do think sports are are very
much on track to come back and
and reopen uh work more across the board
and so even that business has been quite
quite resilient i mean lambda school um
there's there's sort of the sense in
which it's like um
there's it's like there's like going to
be there should be like unlimited demand
for like a product that enables you to
uh you know you don't have to spend
anything up front um
your your risk is that you're putting in
your time
and they only succeed if they help you
earn a lot more money if they accelerate
your income
um so in theory like if they can
actually deliver on that promise like to
a mass
customer base there shouldn't in theory
be unlimited demand for that
again there's still a lot to prove but
in theory should be
unlimited demand um and then there's
this sense in which
the one that i'm um the one that i'm
actually
uh you know the trend that i'm like most
bullish on is
i do think there are all of these like
essential workers that
that have to work in the real world
still um
and uh and and do jobs for us like the
people who keep the
power lines up and uh and um and those
folks are actually really important
and we it's easy to forget about them
when everyone's locked at home on zoom
and we have a company in our portfolio
rig up which is one of our largest
investors
which is a platform for those workers
that get matches them with jobs
provides them with a suite of services
and benefits sort of two-sided labor
marketplace for
um for um for the for skilled trade
workers
um you know renewable and renewables
construction defense energy etc
um and uh and i'm actually very bullish
on that area because i
i do think somehow we we uh we it's easy
to forget about about all those folks i
think
plays a role for them as well yeah that
makes a ton of sense
and it feels like uh when you look at
each individual business i think your
point about the resiliency
uh the the one thing that as soon as
this all started uh
i i said to somebody that i don't think
a lot of people outside of venture
investing understood was like these
businesses are built in many cases to
lose money for long periods of time
so in the non-venture world like going
to zero revenue is
absolutely catastrophic like you have no
cash flow you can't operate your
business you don't have big reserves
you know small businesses they have
basically like three weeks of cash on
average all this stuff
venture capital businesses are
capitalized in a way where sometimes
they're going you know 18
24 months with burning the cash that
they've raised and so
in some weird way they were actually set
up um to
withstand it a little bit better right
structurally but obviously if
you cover sports and sports are gone you
know that's not good either
yeah um yeah so there's there's i i
i think in our portfolio it's been a
accel major accelerant for maybe
40 of the portfolio it's been neutral
for maybe
uh you know maybe 30 of the portfolio
and then it's been pretty bad for maybe
30 percent of the portfolio
when being honest yeah i i think that's
a pretty uh
pretty fair distribution um all right
any uh any hot takes or
uh or last uh opinions in terms of where
the world is going
uh or or things you're thinking about um
uh uh the um the world's too dangerous
for hot cakes right now
it's my hot take you're not wrong my
friend you're not wrong
uh where can people find you or find out
more about bedrock if they want to get
in touch
awesome so i have this you know that's
really trying to get subscribers for
this nascent youtube channel that i just
launched a few weeks ago
jeff lewis tv jeff with the g geo app
app on youtube subscribe to me on
youtube follow me on twitter
just glue j-u-s-t-g-l-e-w
uh thanks so much for having me on pomp
always a pleasure
what is on jeff lewis tv i'm gonna go
tweet this as soon as we get done but
what is tv
dude a bunch of my temperature checks
it's the moment i'm trying to make it
one of the new distribution pipes so
we've got to get
and we're going to be adding a lot more
a lot more interesting content so we've
got to get that got to get that out
there i
appreciate any help you can offer all
right we'll do it again in the future
jeff thanks so much
thanks bye